um talk about growing up in la which is
like for people who don't know it's like
a tv show that you that you're behind
that
um
it skits it's uh
how many episodes did you do i did five
this season five um self-produced yep
yeah so uh give us like a rundown of
growing up in la because that's on your
youtube channel right yes on my youtube
channel um growing up in la is the
scarce comedy show uh i created um with
the help of
um my lady mike williams she um she
helped me um
figure out the concept and basically um
i wanted to do a sketch show like
all my life about my experience of
growing up in la but also tying the
things that
inspired me as a kid right so she was
like okay boom we're gonna get together
look just how you write this so i
structured it and um i do skits where it
consists of me sitting on the couch
looking at tv and i'm reenacting this
[ __ ] on tv like cops cheaters [ __ ] like
that and it's just a variety sketch so
like all the [ __ ] i watched um robert
townsend's um
uh uh um what was the name of the show
robert townsend's a a a a a
a partners in crime um the day chapel
show the wayne's brother jamie foxx show
martin all that so i i incorporated all
those things into this sketch show which
allowed you to see the black and brown
community getting together and then you
see like these different situations and
these different characters and
it's just like something dope for the
city just really la based but you get
the hints of different spots when you
can watch certain things and they're
like oh [ __ ] that resonates with where
i'm from yeah it's also impressive
because like you know i think in 2022 or
2021 when when you first put the
episodes out like you feel like
a lot of content creators
traditionally will depend on
a machine
or a
developmental deal or something to do
what you did yeah when now we have our
own plan like youtube like you know what
i'm saying like there's really no excuse
if you got an idea
you put your head down save your money
figure it out yeah you should be able to
execute your ideas like
was it for you was it like
did you try to shop that idea around
before you just decided to put it out or
were you like let me put it out first
yeah and then garner interest and yeah
um my whole thing was i wanted to do it
myself like with the show
produced it myself i written it myself i
got the cast myself everything i more so
was like i'm not waiting for nobody to
give me opportunity i'm gonna give
myself opportunity because a lot of
times we tend to wait on other people to
throw in that life raft instead of
jumping out in the ocean and swimming
yourself and figuring it out so i was
like i'm gonna do this show my damn self
and if it blows up that way it goes that
way but with me doing it myself i'mma
learn the importance of independence and
figuring it out on my own so i'm not at
a crossroad to if this [ __ ] don't work i
don't know how to do this i'm gonna do
this now and we're gonna see what
happens